what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder I'm your host
Warren Thompson and we got some great
news about Deadpool 3 today but it turns
out that the plot might not actually be
what we were thinking it would be yes
Deadpool is going to travel the
Multiverse yes Wolverine is going to be
with him the entire time and yes a lot
of killing and fighting is going to
happen but why is the question this was
something we weren't always 100 sure
about yes we know that Deadpool is going
to have the time travel device that
cable had in Deadpool 2 and we even saw
him start to use it in the post-credits
scene so we naturally assumed that the
reason why Deadpool was traveling the
Multiverse was kind of just because he
felt like it however that doesn't seem
to be the case according to a new report
and I gotta say if this ends up being
true fans are going to be incredibly
excited especially comic book story fans
because if this ends up true it does
look like we are getting a Deadpool
kills the Fox Universe storyline and of
course other universes as well until he
eventually makes his way to the MCU and
what we're hearing if it's true involves
the X-Men in a much greater way than we
thought were going to be involved with
Deadpool 3. in fact the story that the
X-Men are going to have in Deadpool 3
again if this is true is simply amazing
and yes this does still involve the TVA
Owen Wilson's character Mobius but not
in the same way they're involved in a
very different way than we thought they
would be and we'll break everything down
but first if you're new be sure to
subscribe so you don't miss out on any
of the latest mcnews and if you'd like
to enter our giveaway all you gotta do
is subscribe and leave a comment down
below this enters you for a chance to
win an Xbox series X A PS5 some Marvel
Legends and DC stuff as well the winner
gets to choose and we pick a winner at
the end of each month now this was
posted anonymously online but a lot of
aspects of what was said actually make a
ton of sense including what Deadpool is
doing traveling throughout the
Multiverse you see when we found out
that Owen Wilson character Mobius was
going to be in Deadpool 3 and the TBA
involved we assumed that they were going
to be chasing Deadpool throughout the
Multiverse trying to capture him and
punish him and put him on trial for
messing with the Multiverse however it
looks like they might actually catch him
in the very beginning of the movie
Deadpool has messed with timelines
already we saw this in the post-credit
of Deadpool 2 and according to this
report on mine Deadpool is arrested in
the beginning of the movie by the TVA
for tampering with the timelines and
this makes sense the TVA captured Loki
and they've captured tons of other
people and it makes sense that they
would be able to capture Deadpool
Deadpool doesn't have any teleporting
powers or really anything that would
kind of make him be able to escape the
TVA he is sneaky and Sly I'll give him
that but the TVA as we saw in Loki
they're pretty good too so apparently
the TVA catches him and then as a
penalty they give him a job to eliminate
a rogue timeline where Magneto has taken
over the world and subjugated Humanity
House of M style it then says that Owen
Wilson gives Deadpool a Handler to keep
him out of trouble now they recently
added the actor Matthew McFadden to the
cast and I'm thinking that this could be
the role that he is playing in Deadpool
3. Deadpool's Handler so to speak
someone from the TVA that is always with
Deadpool to keep a watch on him to make
sure that he doesn't go into another
timeline or try to escape or try to
Simply rule the timeline that he's in
but things get even crazier as it says
Deadpool teams up with the Wolverine of
this world the world that he gets sent
to to eliminate where Xavier and the fox
X-Men have joined Magneto and basically
kill everyone so right away I gotta say
if this is true if they're going to a
universe where Magneto rules with the
X-Men as well and all of Magneto's team
the Brotherhood of evil mutants and all
of the X-Men are ruling this universe
and have killed almost everybody else
that is something I definitely want to
see and this would make sense that he
would get Deadpool to try and take down
this universe because the TVA yeah
they're strong and they can handle maybe
one person at a time but no way they
could take on Magneto alone or Professor
X alone let alone both of them and their
entire team of mutants I doubt the TVA
could take down this timeline which is
why they need Deadpool somebody out of
the ordinary who has already broke the
laws who they don't really care if he
dies or not however they've probably
monitored Deadpool and know that he is
sneaky and of course he has a way of
doing things that aren't very
traditional which would probably make
him the perfect person to do this job
especially if you consider that he kind
of does know the other characters we
haven't really seen him meet anybody but
in Deadpool 2 they pretty much implied
that the X-Men know who he is I mean
obviously we know Colossus does and he's
been trying to recruit him to be an
X-Men so we can assume Professor X knows
who he is maybe Magneto as well but
here's something extremely cool that
this mentions it says there are other
MCU characters but very brief mentions
mostly like how Magneto's X-Men killed
all the Avengers it says Magneto can
control the metal and Thor's hammer and
has it but it's mostly its own thing
from there Deadpool and Wolverine kill
everyone now despite whatever or whoever
this report is coming from a lot of this
I think makes sense for Deadpool 3 and
how would you make Deadpool 3 really
really exciting and connect it to the
Marvel Cinematic Universe well you would
do it this way this movie we already
know from what we've heard from
producers and actors Etc is going to
really be about the fox universe and
Deadpool leaving that Universe to go
into the Marvel Cinematic Universe so we
already knew this movie was going to
give us both universes and what's a
great way to kind of segue that and
combine those two universes very briefly
well have Deadpool go into a universe
where the X-Men and the Avengers did
exist together and depending on what the
Avengers team was at that moment yeah
I'm gonna say Magneto Professor X and
the rest of the X-Men they win
especially if yes Magneto could control
Thor's hammer made by uru metal they
take out one of the strongest Avengers
right away yeah they can beat him but
Deadpool given an assignment by the TVA
to kill an entire timeline this is what
we've been talking about since Deadpool
3 was first announced we were basically
thinking we were going to get a Deadpool
kills the Marvel Universe film but it
would be the old Universe the fox
universe so essentially we would get a
Deadpool kills the fox Universe film and
a lot of what's been said lines up with
what we've been thinking however the TVA
capturing Deadpool that makes sense
because like I said they could pretty
much capture him him by himself sure but
this universe where the X-Men would rule
yeah they could not take them down they
would be way too strong and they have
abilities Magneto could simply take all
the metal around him and kill all the
TVA agents really quickly Professor X
could take over their minds right away
or use telekinesis to strip them of
their weapons right away Nightcrawler
could teleport them basically the GBA is
a group of people well variants really
who don't necessarily have powers yes
they have the ability to prune but the
X-Men could definitely stop them and
since we know that Owen Wilson's
character is a good guy Mobius he's
probably tired of losing TVA agents and
friends to this specific timeline and
much like in the Loki series he got Loki
to take on Sylvie it makes sense to get
Deadpool a mutant who's not necessarily
good you know but very good at his job
he gets him to take on the X-Men and it
makes sense that he would find Wolverine
because it would make sense given
Wolverine's attitude and mindset that
Wolverine would not join the X-Men in
this timeline and considering the fact
that Wolverine is all metal and he would
be going up against Magneto it would
also make sense that Wolverine would
kind of just stay away now I'm not sure
how this will really work in the movie
when Wolverine decides to go up against
Magneto we've seen that happen before
and it doesn't really end well but there
are ways around it and essentially this
would be kind of a hey if you kill
Magneto wolverines in the fight type of
thing and Deadpool could probably manage
to be sneaky enough to get in there and
try to kill Magneto first but just
imagine what this could be like Ryan
Reynolds and Hugh Jackman already said
that this is going to be action-packed
they've already teased us with Deadpool
and Wolverine fighting each other and
that could actually be when Deadpool
first arrives to the universe and tries
to recruit Wolverine Wolverine might
think that he's part of the X-Men so he
might attack Deadpool whether he thinks
Deadpool's there to recruit him for the
X-Men team or kill him off there's gonna
be a pretty big battle between Wolverine
and Deadpool now ultimately what I
believe is going to happen is Deadpool
is going to state that he's a big fan of
Wolverine because of course we're
breaking the fourth wall here and he's
already time traveled to the pass to see
Wolverine so he's gonna basically State
hey I came to specifically look for you
because I want to kill everybody else
everyone in this world but you do you
want to help me and he's gonna say yes
whether that takes some time or whether
that's right up front he's gonna
eventually say yes because keep in mind
we've heard that this Wolverine is going
to be a little bit different than the
one that we've had before and what I
think that means is he's going to be a
little less serious and maybe a little
bit more funny that way he kind of fits
into the comedic action Vibe for this
movie because that's what Deadpool is
it's a lot of crazy awesome action but
it's also a comedy it's really funny so
when they say Wolverine is going to be a
little bit different that's what I
interpret that as so it looks like we
could be getting a movie where Deadpool
and Wolverine are working for the TVA to
kill an entire timeline that is
dominated and ruled by the X-Men and
Magneto we've already heard that the fox
X-Men are going to be in Deadpool 3 and
this would be an incredible way to have
them be a pretty significant part of the
movie now ultimately we know that
Deadpool is going to make his way to the
MCU and hopefully that means Hugh
Jackman's Wolverine come in with him but
we've also heard that those Fox X-Men
will appear in secret Wars as well but
keep in mind the Multiverse is huge
there are plenty of other universes
where the X-Men exist and they're not
evil and dominating an entire universe
so even if Deadpool and Wolverine
managed to kill everybody of course
there are other universes and other
versions of the fox X-Men who could pop
up in secret Wars but either way I'm
really excited for Deadpool 3 and if
even some of this is included in the
movie I think it's going going to be
fantastic but let us know your thoughts
in the comments down below would you
like to see this happen or would you
change something let us know also don't
forget to like the video and subscribe
and leave a comment so you can enter our
giveaway for a chance to win a PS5 Xbox
series X some Marvel Legends items and
some DC stuff as well you can always
follow us on Instagram and Twitter and
as always thank you all so much for
watching woof woof